yeah everybody's excited to see las
vegas come back to life and this weekend
uh
we're expecting to see a lot of people
coming here the las vegas trip
uh we went we're at a number of places
on the strip earlier today and it's
really
getting busier out there businesses on
this trip are excited to see
this busy weekend we want to have fun we
want to see different people the weather
feels good this is why we came out here
las vegas is coming back to life we've
both been vaccinated and
so we feel good getting back to normal
after being down for a year
people are happy to see their favorite
vegas attractions stratosphere
the high roller fremont street fremont
street is a must
april tourism numbers released thursday
show las vegas is rebounding fast
businesses are noticing it business is
picked up
i mean we're at 2019 levels now trial
mexican kitchen on the link promenade is
welcoming the rush of visitors
assistant manager greg waters says the
city is starting to feel normal we're
crushed every weekend works
like for this coming memorial day we're
expecting to be a mad house
all weekend long economists say
government stimulus mixed with pent-up
demand
is making las vegas rebound stronger
than expected
priceline predicted las vegas to be the
number one travel destination
in the united states for memorial day
weekend quote unquote experts
came out with statements to the effect
that it was going to be two years three
years before vegas
rebounded uh it's not the case we're
seeing
a steady flow of people and businesses
going this way thank goodness
tony carnevale owns carnivale gallery in
the caesars forum
he took advantage of the pandemic
turning the city's never before seen
calmness into art pieces like this photo
now he is happy to see las vegas light
up again incredible memories that are
evoked from that experience and it's one
that i hope we never have to live again
now back out here live businesses say
las vegas is going to be even busier now
that the golden knights are
playing at home tomorrow night they say
it will be a hectic evening here on the
las vegas strip but they are looking
forward
to all the business reporting live here
on the las vegas trip this evening joe
moeller news now